well I hope you like Dalmatians or
you're really not gonna like this movie
well okay I shouldn't be that mean to it
but let's just be honest it's a bunch of
Dalmatians they walk around they look
cute they talk they bark they know no
just do cutesy stuff if you like that
you're gonna love this film if not it's
a bit of a bore I guess there are a few
things that stand out about it like the
villain Cruella De Vil which ever since
the live-action version has become one
of the most infamous villains of all
time and she is a lot of fun it's just a
great design sort of this weak fragile
woman under this gigantic hairy
monstrous fur coat she smoked glamorous
and hideous at the same time and it
leaves a pretty cool design and the
characters a lot of fun to constantly
screaming constantly yelling but always
trying to look fabulous while doing it
her motivation is to get as many
dalmatian puppies as she can to make a
bajillion fur coats and once 15 puppies
of our main characters get abducted
which somehow makes the front pages for
some reason the search is on to go and
find the rest of the characters are not
bad they're just kind of phoned in the
husband and wife are a typical nice
husband and wife the side characters are
typical sort of dopey side characters I
think the only one I ever really got
into was the cat because there was just
this feeling he would never give up I
mean yeah he's constantly screaming he's
constantly running but he's always
sticking with the puppies look at that
they're about to bash their brains on
he's still there trying to protect them
that's awesome go kitty I guess part of
the joke of the movie is how seriously
they're treating the dogs like how the
husband is just as paranoid about the
birth of the puppies as well the dog is
or how when the puppies are kidnapped
the maid goes out screaming into the
streets and like I said it makes
front-page papers no no for me I never
found it that funny so I guess it never
gotten any laughs I guess the climax is
kind of fun it is rare that you see a
car chase in a Disney film especially
with karela behind the wheel and I do
enjoy how the car continues to get
stripped down it almost starts to turn
into just as big a monster as she is but
aside from that I don't think
as the charm is something like Lady and
the Tramp head or even the animation for
it although I guess it was sort of
groundbreaking and that they were
testing rotoscope and copying and so
forth and how many puppies they could
show but I don't know if that makes it
one of the better Disney films if you're
a dog fan or a Dalmatian fan you'll
probably like it fine but if not it's
not horrible it's just not man engages
take it for what it's worth not one of
my personal faves
you